bonjour bonjour alors aujourd'hui je
vais pas vous parler de ma société je
vais plutôt vous parler d'un sujet qui
me tient à coeur qui est la santé de
demain et comment on consommera notre
santé demain et je vais commencer avec
un peu de mythologie asklepios diot grec
de la médecine avait deux filles igier
la protectrice et panacée la guérisseuse
malheureusement depuis des siècles nos
sociétés occidentales n'ont considéré
que panacée la guérisseuse avec une
médecine curative qui traitent les
maladies on voit que notre consommation
évoluent on voit que le coût des
maladies augmente et donc j'ai essayé de
comprendre comment les nouvelles
technologies sont en train de changer la
donne et comment les nouvelles
technologies nous permettent de passer
d'une médecine curative à une médecine
préventive qui ne va pas traiter la
maladie mais justement qui va la
prévenir
donc quand j'ai regardé ce qui avait un
peu sur le marché en termes de nouvelles
technologies au niveau de la santé je me
suis dit waouh
comment je vais réussir à parler de tout
ça j'en ai bien pour la journée on m'a
donné dix minutes
donc je me suis focalisé uniquement sur
une maladie une maladie malheureusement
qui n'est pas endémique qui touche
beaucoup de monde et qui concerne le
diabète le diabète dans le monde
actuellement en 2013
ces 400 millions de personnes j'ai bien
dit 400 millions de personnes et dans 20
ans il y aura 50 % de plus de personnes
qui auront le diabète 600 millions de
personnes dans 20 ans et le plus dingue
c'est que il ya des personnes tous les
ans qui meurent soixante dix mille
personnes l'année dernière qui sont mes
rendu du diabète en france et c'est un
coup ces 12 milliards d'euros le
traitement du diabète en france
donc comment on n'a pas encore trouvé le
remède miracle
donc j'ai essayé de chercher comment on
pouvait faire pour pour améliorer tout
ça la qualité de vie des gens diminuer
le coût est en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est qu'on m'a
pas attendu
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent
en termes de technologies là dedans et
je vais prendre ma casquette de docteur
en pharmacie
je vais vous parler un peu du diabète le
diabète qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un taux de glucose anormalement
élevé dans le sang pour la simple et
bonne raison qu'il ya une déficience au
niveau du pancréas et que le pancréas ne
sécrète plus d'insuline pour réguler
donc finalement je suis diabétique
on va dire que je suis diabétique
aujourd'hui dès que j'ai un peu trop de
glucose dans le sang je me prends mon
shoot d'insuline et hop ça redescend
mais attention il faut pas que je prenne
trop d'insuline parce que sinon bah mon
glucose redevient trop bas et je suis en
hypoglycémie et donc l'un dans l'autre
que ce soit trop de glycémie ou pas
assez assez mauvais pour ma santé et ça
peut entraîner des maladies des maladies
annexes donc la difficulté c'est
d'arriver à bien maîtriser ce taux de
glucose
il ya quelques années j'avais un stylo
injecteur pour me mettre quatre à six
fois par jour des chutes de d'insuline
par non malheureusement j'avais du mal à
contrôler donc les technologies m'ont
permis de me brancher une pompe à
insuline c'est à dire que toutes les 5
minutes 10 minutes je vais avoir une
petite dose d'insuline qui va me
permettre de réguler mon taux de glucose
mais qu'est ce qui se passe ici ma pompe
là commença à déconner si elle s'arrête
de fonctionner je fais un coma moi je
fais un coma hyperglycémique et donc
c'est pas possible ça donc quatre à six
fois par jour je suis obligé avec mon
lecteur de glycémie de mesurer mon taux
de glucose pour voir s'il est bon et
tous les toutes les semaines tous les
mois je vais voir je vais voir mon
médecin traitant et je veux dire
regardez mon taux de glycémie là il est
bon sur le mois ça va pas là vous étiez
un peu trop mais pendant un mois quand
j'étais trop au niveau de ma glycémie
ç'a eu des séquelles sur ma santé et ses
séquelles elles ont un coût sur ma vie
sur ma santé mais aussi elles ont un
coût de traitement si dommage devient
aveugle parce que j'ai trop de sucre
dans mon sens on va me traiter aussi une
cécité
donc c'est là qu'intervient un objet que
vous avez tous dans la poche
un smartphone ça paraît tout con mais il
ya des startups heures il ya des
industriels qui se sont dit et pourquoi
le lecteur de glycémie on le branche pas
sûr sur le téléphone portable comme ça
en temps réel je vais pouvoir suivre ma
glycémie au fil du temps mais moi on
s'en fout c'est mon docteur qui va
pouvoir suivre ma glycémie en temps réel
pour me dire attention cédric là il
faudrait que tout augmente la dose
d'insuline règle la pompe est donc
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a eu un
changement de paradigme où je devenais
acteur de ma santé en connectant tout
mais data dans mon téléphone portable et
d'ailleurs l'aef dié aux états unis s'y
est pas trompé elle a dit c'est génial
moi j'avais l'habitude de mettre des
tampons je valide tel médicament ou tel
dispositif médical sur le marché
américain est là pour la première fois
on se retrouve avec une application
smartphone qui se retrouvent à gré quand
même par la fda aux états unis
qui dit maintenant un médecin peut
prescrire une application est donc aux
états unis vous allez voir votre médecin
vous avez du diabète il vous dit mon
dieu où tu veux pas prendre le
médicament
tu vas prendre une application mais ça
sauve des vies et le coût de
l'application est dérisoire c'est 100 $
par personne par mois comparé au coût du
diabète qui est de 15000 euros par an
par personne
donc là on le transpose à d'autres
maladies depuis il ya une dizaine
d'applications aux états unis qui ont
été approuvés et que les médecins
peuvent prescrire et on est en train de
changer complètement la donne
il ya quelques années on n'aurait pas
pensé prescrire se voir prescrire une
une application sur smartphone
mais moi cédric qui est le diabète et
c'est bien marrant mais tu m'emmerdes
parce que il faut encore que je me pique
le doigt
quatre à six fois par jour même si
j'étais en application donc comment on
fait pour que l'on mesure la glycémie en
temps réel et la google qui est partout
c'est dit moi j'ai la technologie et
fait un deal avec novartis géant de la
pharmacie et là il met en place une
lentille au cul
r qui va calculer notre glycémie dans le
liquide lacrymal de l'oeil en temps réel
donc qu'est ce qui se passe c'est que
demain vous aurez une lentille de
contact qui va communiquer avec votre
smartphone mais aussi avec la pompe à
insuline en temps réel sanofi non n'en
reste dix mois je vais arrive à innover
et prépare une montre connectés qui elle
aussi grâce à la peau va calculer la
glycémie et on se rend bien compte
toutes ces avancées technologiques
permettent d'améliorer la qualité de vie
de tous ces patients mais c'est vrai
pour le diabète mais c'est vrai dans
toutes les maladies mais là qu'est ce
que je fais je traite la maladie
donc je suis toujours dans une démarche
de médecine curative donc comment on
évolue
si on prend une diabète il ya 7 millions
de personnes aux états unis rien qu'aux
états unis qui vivent avec le diabète et
qui sont pas au courant donc le plus
tard je détecte la maladie le plus
d'effet sont déjà fait sur mon corps
donc c'est là que google 2 avec une de
ses filiales qui s'appelle to want is
you and me propose une médecine
prédictive médecine prédictive qui fait
très peur en france 1 on est sur
l'analyse de l'année l'adn pour 100 $
100 $
je vais envoyer un peu de salive à cette
société qui va me faire une cartographie
de mon adn et me dire attention pour tel
tell tale et maladies vous avez des
gènes vous avez une prédisposition
génétique qui fait que vous avez plus de
probabilités que la moyenne des
individus de contracter le diabète est
donc même si ça fait peur il est où
l'intérêt il est de se dire si j'ai des
jeunes qui me prédisposait à avoir telle
maladie mais je vais essayer de d'avoir
une hygiène de vie différente un arrêté
tout ce qui pourrait accélérer cette
maladie mais surtout je vais me faire
dépister tous les ans pour la maladie
comme ça quand j'aurai le diabète
je serai sûr que je la traiterait de
manière
la plus appropriée le plus rapidement
possible pour éviter des effets
secondaires et des séquelles donc voilà
comment les nouvelles technologies nous
permettent aussi un diagnostic et une
prise en charge plus rapide des maladies
mais continuons dans l'idée moi j'ai
déjà la maladie bon il était gentil mais
j'aimerais j'aimerais arrêter même une
lentille me mettre la lentille tous les
jours et c'est là qu'on va encore plus
loin parce que la science c'est fabuleux
aujourd'hui des chercheurs français sont
sur le point d'inventer un pancréas
un pancréas artificiel qui va sécréter
lui-même de l'insuline alors peut-être
que demain ça sera même par impression
3d qui sait dans chaque hôpitaux vous
aurez une imprimante 3d qui à la demande
tu veux quoi toi je me prends à coeur
aujourd'hui l'ajustant que j'espère que
ça marchera comme ça et j'espère que ce
soit que ça sera accessible à tout le
monde donc intrinsèquement oui je pense
que les technologies nous permettent de
passer d'une médecine curative à une
médecine préventive en améliorant
l'hygiène de vie des citoyens en
diagnostiquant plus rapidement les
maladies et en important des solutions
qui améliorent la qualité de vie mais
au-delà de ça de quoi on parle
avec les nouvelles techno en parle dans
powerpoint
c'est le citoyen qui reprend la donne
qui n'est plus passif dans son
traitement cg à une médecine qui devient
participatif j'interagis avec mon
médecin
je n'attends pas qu'on me dise tu dois
prendre tel traitement et une fois tous
les mois quand je vais voir mon médecin
je suis acteur de ma santé et moi
aujourd'hui ce que je veux c'est que
vous moi les pouvoirs publics s'emparent
de sa ai dit comment on va se servir des
nouvelles technologies pour faire
évoluer la médecine demain et non pas
qu'on soit dans un principe de
précaution comme on a l'habitude de le
faire en france ou statu quo attention
ça peut être dangereux problème
d'éthique sur la génomique problème de
données comme on trace les données est
ce que ça va pas partir auprès d'un
assurances qui va vouloir les racheter
bien sûr que c'est des questions qui se
posent mais on peut on peut les résoudre
et on n'a pas besoin de freiner
l'innovation parce qu'il ya ces
questions de dérives qui pourrait se
poser donc ce soir ce que j'ai envie de
dire c'est on est acteur de notre santé
nous sommes acteurs de votre santé vous
êtes acteur de votre santé merci